we should have listened to the theorist
a little bit more a lot of our
experiments were designed to be null
experiments and we weren't particularly
interested in finding something and we
didn't particularly pay attention to the
theorists who were telling us if you're
looking for small variations in the
temperature you ought to be looking on
scales of the order of a degree or below
and that's reflected in the design of
the Kobe satellite the experiment that
one George smoo his Nobel Prize was
consciously designed to look for small
changes in temperature different parts
of the sky but at the wrong scale at 10°
scale instead of one degre scale we
could have done much better might even
have found the anisotropies earlier had
the experiment been designed better and
had George and the rest of us listen to
the theorist